The audience questions have been pouring in
sort of like a firehose and maybe not surprisingly,
as we get closer to the November election,
more and more of the questions relate to the
election.
But not all of them.
The first one I got is how much of America
will refuse the Corona virus vaccine?
And will this prevent us from getting to herd
immunity?
This is it's really an empirical question.
It's not mean we can speculate about motives
and we can look at polling to figure out part
of the answer.
But part of this is an empirical question
in terms of will we get to that magic number
that we need in order to reach herd immunity?
Now, herd immunity, there's a little bit of
confusion about herd immunity.
There are folks who e-mail me and I can tell
that they don't realize the level of immunity
to reach herd immunity depends on the disease.
So if a disease is much more contagious, like,
for example, measles, which has an R value
of somewhere between 16 and 18, I'm going
from memory here.
Measles is so contagious, it spreads so easily
where it can be aerosolized, where you go
into an elevator after someone has already
left the elevator and they might have been
carrying it and you could catch it.
It's a it's a huge level of contagion, far
more than corona virus or the flu.
It's so contagious that you need like 95 percent
of immunity to reach herd immunity, which
is why it's so important that everybody be
vaccinated against measles when the condition
is less contagious, when the disease is less
contagious, like corona virus, which is more
contagious than flu, but far less contagious
than measles.
The level of immunity required for herd immunity
is lower, and the estimates are that for coronavirus
it's about 70 percent rather than measles
is 95 because corona virus spreads less easily
than measles.
So we need to get to 70 percent.
Now, you can get to that through a combination
of naturally acquired immunity from people
who have recovered from the disease and immunizations,
people who have been vaccinated.
Now, there's an open question as to how long
you are immune after recovering from coronavirus.
We don't know the answer to that yet.
But hypothetically, you could get your 70
percent.
A five percent of the population has recovered
naturally from Corona virus and two thirds,
66 percent get vaccinated.
That gets you 71 percent.
You are at herd immunity.
The sad reality of the situation is that we
have two poles, one from right around June
one and one from July one, roughly where only
about half of Americans say they plan to get
the vaccine.
There's an AP NORC poll from May 27 where
50 percent of Americans say they would get
a corona virus vaccine.
And then June 30th on different poll, which
says that, again, about 50 percent of Americans
plan to get the vaccine.
Now, it's been five weeks since that latest
poll.
It's conceivable that because of the continued
spread.
Deaths back up to 50, you know, a thousand
twelve hundred fifteen hundred a day that
more people are now planning to get the vaccine.
Now, this is simple math.
If you need 70 and half plan to get the vaccine
to get to herd immunity, that means you need
an additional 20 percent of the country to
recover.
Naturally, 20 percent of the country is about
66 million people.
That would imply a 660000 person death toll,
estimating roughly one percent of those who
get the virus die.
Now, that's the simple math.
The reality is when you look at more complex
and detailed contagion models, you don't literally
need 70 percent in for this reason.
And I want to try to explain this correctly.
You are right.
You don't come into contact with everybody
in the country.
So in reality, your risk of contagion is not
so much about is the country level or at a
country level, do we have 70 percent immunity?
But it's more related to what's going on in
your immediate surroundings.
And because we have dramatically different
urban versus rural or rural, as Trump says,
situations in the United States, you probably
would get up a practical, practically speaking,
herd immunity somewhere short of 70 percent,
because not the entire population is not regularly
coming into contact with the entire population.
You're mostly coming into contact with some
limited group of people when you're going
to work, when you're going to your grocery
store, et cetera.
And so there are the real number is a little
short of 70 percent.
But regardless if only half the country plans
to get the vaccine, we need 20 percent to
get the virus in order to reach herd immunity.
And that means a lot of people are going to
die.
That would be another 500000 people compared
to where we are right now.
Very, very ugly.
I hope that it's not the case.
I hope people change.
Their minds.
But the polling so far is extremely disturbing